reject nation i can't tell the difference
between my waking life and whatever that was
oscar is here for this reaction for the rest of
the life and dreams or something like that yeah
anyway we got ourselves a moon night clip today
we got ourselves a screener in in the email
now they sent over four but apparently
three and four aren't finished because
they won't spoil stuff so i think we're
just gonna watch only the first episode
this weekend we're going to record our
reaction forward and we'll wait till actually
obviously the show is up to publish it we're
not going to skip ahead we're just going to be a
couple days ahead of you guys for the actual
show but we'll be on time with you weekly
right after that leave a like
leave a look in the comment boxes
cool yes conscious
dope don't trust her you've seen
the movie devil don't trust her
oh yeah
fine thank you lost my contact lens i
hope you find it electrical problems
in the building isn't it always the same
isn't it are we back on the fifth floor
yes the thief my friend claire is here i'm
visiting her she's expecting me oh what's going on
dude you know what's happening
in that uh trailer i noticed
was that he can't tell the difference between
that's right or a nightmare it's not my good
nightmare yeah that was cool it is nice to see
that marvel is staying true to the word with
keeping it truly feeling like a supernatural
horror show i hope like this kind of vibe this
tone that they're emitting here i hope that
remains present throughout the series because a
lot of times when you know they're teasing horror
it can be like oh yeah in the beginning they start
doing some horror stuff but once he's like oh i
know who i am i'm actually mark spector i'm moon
nut i'm a badass mofo then it's just like mainly
just action tone like that that's kind of my
concern is that it'll it'll just switch to action
to drive only and and kind of sacrifice some of
the horror tone once we've uh uncovered enough
of the mystery it is cool to see that marvel is
truly honing in on horror like in terms of the mcu
i feel like i've said this once or twice before
but this does seem like the most horror it seems
the most overtly horror yeah i mean it seems like
we keep getting this sort of looming promise of
horror really really coming into the mcu in a
way that isn't just like for a scene or two to
enhance the peril or whatever i feel like as long
as we have steven grant there's that potential
for the horror to take hold because you know yeah
obviously mark specter is gonna be much more in
control they're gonna play bad to the bone every
time he shows up he's gonna put on sunglasses
every time i feel like this is perhaps the true
chance to really have something where horror is
a flavor throughout and that's going to inform you
know a lot of the action in the show because too
like the indiana jones movies which they've said
are partly an inspiration for this do have their
elements of horror throughout like most of the
ruins and temples and places he's going they do a
nice job to bridge that fun action with horror and
i feel like we're probably going to get at least
a taste of that here and that makes me really
excited horror is probably my favorite genre and
i keep waiting for that one that's gonna scratch
my itch as a horror fan as well as as a fan of you
know the marvel universe and their characters
and whatnot oh yeah the physicality on kanchi
there in that moment looks really good
it looks like a definite blend of actor
and costume mixed with some cgi specifically on
the hallway shots when he's walking down there
but then the close-up of the prosthetic of the
head looks really cool i love the details on it
it makes me wonder story-wise what they're doing
though with moon knight because they've already
shown they're mixing up some timelines and and
some character work here like this personality
of stephen grant if you didn't tell me with
stephen grant i would assume it is the personality
of jake lockley who was like the taxi cab driver
and stuff where it's like steven grant in the
comics is more like a wealthy philanthropist
and such steven grant here does not look like
a dude made of money whatsoever and there was
this other trailer that i watched over the weekend
that showed him stephen grant interacting with
mark spector and it's like in this show they're
showing that stephen graham will probably be the
primary protagonist the personality you're hanging
out with the most at least in the beginning like
i'm wondering if they're going to do some type of
shift halfway through the season where okay now
that we've unpacked what's going on here with this
person now we're going to shift gears where
the perspective of the show is mainly going
to be coming from mark spector himself but in that
trailer i remember mark spector being like stephen
you weren't supposed to know any of this like
he had sort of this protective quality towards
stephen like he was trying to shield him from all
this and it seemed very purposeful that he would
do that and the other trailers you see them go to
egypt so the presumption i had was that the whole
country possession already took place that already
happened parts of the trailers are not making me
think is the country possession supposed to happen
later after he goes and visits the museum and such
this is a conscious possession supposed to happen
then however i'm kind of wondering now what if
mark specter and this whole dialogue has only been
for people who know what the hell we're talking
if you don't know what the hell moonlight is
i'm just noticing like it's all about gibberish
but i'm wondering now if like mark specter
at the point in his life where he's at
actually tried suppressing um konchu and instead
tried making like stephen grant the dominant
personality to hide consciou for a reason and
now kanchu mark specter coinciding are going to
be reawakened that's not what they do in the
comics i know sometimes mark spector would
suppress the weaker personality so he can be as
strong as possible now i wonder if they'll do
another flip here since i've already been changing
some stuff just from the footage alone we'll see
i mean it looks looks cool it looks cool i mean
in terms of horror it's like nothing really like
uniquely horror about it what's exciting
is the fact that marvel's doing horror yeah
yeah that's fair it would be nice to see
them bring their own proprietary brand of
unique horror but yeah i'll take any horror
to start this is nothing like near we've seen
a hallway gag and someone's showing up behind
you a thousand times yeah so but it's exciting
that marvel's finally doing it that's basically
the reason to be excited about it because it's
also opened up a door for them to do more unique
horror down the road it's like as long as that
door is open as long as they've opened that gate
to the upside down yes stranger closes it again
yeah anyway guys moon knight we're done
yes i can't tell the difference between
when the video's over and when we do
andrew hayes andrew i don't know where you've been
i don't know why you don't give a [ __ ] about
us anymore but it makes me feel really happy we
have someone as loyal as you who will just stay
pledged without even realizing it not complain
whatsoever just be like you know what i don't even
watch their stuff anymore in fact i unsubscribe
from their main youtube channel but i'm here still
just because i think it's a tax write-off to keep
my card pledged on their patreon page i don't know
why we would be and if the government comes to
calling to find out about us i'm ratting you out
but andrew thank you for being loyal you are one
of our first ever patrons and the amount of time
we've been here you've never once seen i don't
think you've even left for a month before i can't
tell the difference between on andrews active on
on patreon or not but thank you for being you did